- I'm Jakeem Grant, I play
for the Miami Dolphins,
and this is "Start, Bench, Cut."
I've been given three options,
one to start, one to bench and one to cut.
Gotta get up outta here.
(Upbeat music)
Start "Friday Night Lights,"
bench "Remember the Titans"
and cut "Rudy."
It was just about one person, man,
it was just about Rudy,
and I know it's all of that, but
"Remember the Titans"
and "Friday Night Lights,"
it was about the team,
and I'm a team player,
so I had to cut "Rudy."
And then "Friday Night
Lights" start, because
I'm from Texas and it's in Texas.
Starting "Madden,"
rephrase that, no I'm not, no I'm not,
I'm starting "Call of Duty,"
benching "GTA"
and cutting "Madden."
Man, them rankings not real, man,
that's not real.
I should be one of the
fastest on the game,
if not the fastest.
One time they did that
to my boy, Keenan Allen,
that's big bro.
Pro Bowl, I don't know
how many times All Pro.
My boy Jarvis Landry, a
whole bunch of guys, man.
I can go down the list.
(Laughs)
Not like that, c'mon man (exhales).
Start "Carter III," uhh,
Imma bench "The Blueprint"
and Imma cut "Get Rich or Die Tryin'."
I'm sorry but, I mean,
you're talking about legends here,
I mean he is a legend but, man.
Honestly, I wouldn't wanna cut neither one
of them to be honest,
but I just had to pick "Get
Rich or Die Tryin'," sorry man,
I'm sorry.
Let's see (laughs).
Starting it's a blessing to be here,
I'm benching the name on
the front of the jerseys
is bigger than the name on the back
and cutting defense wins championships.
Even though,
it's true, defense wins championships,
but I mean, a blessing is a blessing,
that's talking about God here, you know,
yeah that's gonna be No. 1.
And nobody's bigger than the team,
so I mean defense, sorry, man,
I gotta cut you.
Cause I play offense, so hey (laughs)
I'm Jakeem Grant, and this
was "Start, Bench, Cut."